sorry your breath stinks man
absolutely stinks reeks can we get a
different interviewer please this guy's
so unprofessional hello to the audience
of unilad i am nick and this is actually
my first ever interview and i am honored
and privileged to be interviewing nicole
milana
what's up mate
honestly i'm such a huge fan of you man
yeah cool cool well if we can make this
quick my friends that would be very much
appreciated all right well um yeah
honestly such a pleasure i'm a huge fan
of your work and um thank you for coming
today yeah let's go there okay first
question
was there a moment when you realized you
were famous well
i don't know when when you have um
so many people watching your videos and
all this type of stuff
you realize that you are actually better
than people
okay fair enough but was there a reason
when you
realized you were famous like when was
the first time you got recognized on the
street sorry your breath stinks man
absolutely stinks reeks
can we get a different interviewer
please this guy's so unprofessional no
one else sorry you're saying that like
i'm not the main option he's not like a
youtuber as well
just a very odd looking guy okay
nicholas daniel out of a dumb oh my lana
you you don't seem to like this question
so um let's just move on we'll move on
to the next one look in that direction
mate because every time you look at me
i'm just catching that horrible breath
okay i'll i'll look in this direction
over here
okay nico where do you see yourself in
20 years time dead probably dead i don't
know
tell me it's not true yeah well that
make some very controversial videos so
i reckon one of them could go left i
really hope you're still making videos
in 20 years i'll be watching them every
day every minute every hour every second
have you got like sweat patches under
your arms
it's a condition
but um
just tell us tell the audience what's
the closest it's gone to going wrong
like a video going wrong
near-death experience maybe closest i
came to being killed
i mean
i got kicked in the back by a random
donnie at starbucks so that was probably
the closest i came to getting killed why
would anyone want to kill you oh god you
know i can't continue can someone give
him some gum yeah
yeah we'll give it to him don't waste
time eh
okay
i think that's better
oh
god
you're the only person on earth who
chewing gum can't help mouthwash
wouldn't save you
i just don't understand why you're being
so mean nico yeah all right fair i'm
just gonna look in this direction
so i can't even look into those
beautiful eyes i'm wearing shades so
freaks like you can't look into my eyes
just let me look at your face one more
time
the way your beard touches your cheeks
those perfectly i can't look at them
anymore
it's not about me and my disgusting
breath it's about you nicole milana the
founder of the nico defense league the
man who changed the world came fifth in
the london mayoral election so please
nico
tell us your best quality
well
my amazing good looks unlike you my
charm my ability to speak to people but
um what would you say are your worst
qualities
how dare you even ask me a question like
that
how dare you are you sick in the head do
i do i look like a person who has bad
qualities no no you don't we all know
you're great nico we all know you're
such an amazing human being i'm drinking
water um
i'm sorry i could punch you in the head
with this bottle no no
please no violence right i know you're a
titan of a man you'll break my face in
half but um yeah we all have things we'd
want to change about ourselves surely
ah
oh my cranium
oh god that hurt how dare you suggest
that i should change me nicola milana
i'm perfect
i'm like you you swipe
should we just
just move on nika i could only profusely
apologize just get the interview over
just ask the next questions man i know
this isn't going well nico
to be honest this has been a nightmare
of an interview completely my fault
but
if you were me
what would you want me to ask you
so i'm doing your job for you you've
actually got me out here doing your job
for you you dry
interviewer oh i have absolutely no
respect for you you schmuck
what would i ask myself why did i even
get myself in this position in the first
place
why'd i bring myself here
sorry very unprofessional of me well
i've got a few more questions here i
don't want to waste your time your
valuable precious time so should we just
go through them quickly hurry up faster
okay well um so if you aren't doing
youtube videos what do you think you'd
be doing instead porn
oh amazing dudes
what category
would you are you wanting to watch or
something
come on
i'm sure everyone can agree with me i'm
a big fan it's very normal
i don't want to watch you
every part of you in every single way
don't smile at me like that
what is wrong with you i feel extremely
uncomfortable it was a joke i'd want to
make nature documentaries
i have no sense of humor okay um let's
just move on to the next question of
three words to describe yourself oh
that's easy yeah caring kind
understanding
and a great listener
that's four words
shut up i'm not here to listen to you
you're here to listen to me how dare you
even question the fact i can't count
but anyways just ask the next questions
think breath okay well
i put so much effort into this one last
question so please just show me some
respect no
um what advice would you give your 15
year old self
these questions are so uncreative
where'd you find a google did you just
google questions to ask no i'm not doing
this interview anymore you're drive
right fix your face get plastic surgery
as well can i also add i'm done
i'm done nico you are useless unilad you
should be ashamed of yourself can we
please sack this man please guys don't
sack me this is all i've got ugly
looking donny as well
i'm out
that nicole milana guy he's evil
never ever meet your heroes he's not
like how you see him on the screen i
always thought he was delightful
i thought he was a great human being and
instead he spat in my face
my mum's gonna be watching this right
now
i told her that we look the same and he
said i'm clapped with a unibrow
yeah like this is a huge moment for me
we are just
meant to be together we are we're just
so amazing we're on fire we're
untouchable right now yeah this is the
most favorite interview that i've ever
done bro this is
the best interview i've ever done legit
after this interview we got we got a toy